[Music]
hello everybody welcome to comedy film
nerds episode 3 55 it's pretty exciting
another first-time yet first-time guests
mallu earbud starve earbuds your body's
in earbud many of his fans have come
over to listen to this since I was on
his show that's the coolest thing I tell
you what is really boobs bird cry should
I never quite sure everybody you know
what I started we open by the way I
think the one thing we definitely
definitely have a common three of us is
we're all massive podcast fans yeah like
I'm a legit in the trenches fans like
you're hardcore you're a hardcore part
podcast listener well I'm like I was
impressive I'm on the road so much that
I'm just in airplanes and i'm like like
i listened to Rogan's live like Rogan
had Leah Remini on the yesterday who's
amazing it was amazing really and a half
way through i was like i think leah
remini want to [ __ ] Rogen anyway um well
I listened I was on the road I was in
New York a couple weeks ago and I was
listening to the one with Bryan Callen
on Rogen oh those are great ones a great
after the best Rogen one that's out
right now is him in bas Rutten embossers
dance partner bas Rutten oh we were on
his podcast we did we feed him yeah yeah
we're on bathroom and we've all been bas
Rutten is a wild man like he has the
greatest stories at one time this guy
got a cue ball stuck in his mouth they
had to break his teeth out i'm not doing
good i'm not good at present but yes so
so um but you know we were talking about
the dollop earlier one of the things
that I think really moves us to is I'm
not promoting people's podcasts in my
intros that I find and I find a good
podcast I'm like hey guys you're gonna
love this episode and then I was like oh
that totally works for everyone's
benefit like course like I personally
high tide raises all boats we said it's
about podcasting it's not we're not
competing traditional media I'm not
computing because if we don't air it if
someone can listen to me and you yeah
like it's totally there's no competition
in different ears at the same time yeah
theoretically but like it's the thing
like traditional media
pits us against each other we got
audition for the same part you know to
mean like my shows on thursday at eight
on ABC or thursday down and NBC you know
gotta fight they make us fight against
each other and in podcasting it's the
more we support each other the better it
is for all of us it's the only numbers
we can guarantee is when you do
someone's podcast you watch fans of them
come over and check you out and go hey
what's a really good episode listen to I
did that with the dollop and I what I
which is really interesting I promoted
them two weeks before they're on my show
I like I in the intros like everyone
check out the dollop it's one of my
favorite new podcasts listen to the rube
the rube is the ones you listen to and
that's just because we ran under and
Dave and I said where do I start it's
the greatest thing where do I start
what's about you wanted to do when I was
on your show you go where do you where
do you tell what do you what would you
tell people to start with comedy film
airs and I'd pick a movie you like yes
but there's a movie we really talk about
that you did go to that I mean it's
great like when I was on your show like
a month or so ago our biggest spike in
sales since we put earbuds for sale with
me on your show okay yeah because I have
a nice is it like one thing the one
compliments I get from my quote unquote
fans is they go um I like that you're
one of us they're like because like
there are people that have podcasts that
are not they do not want to hang out
with their fans right they don't want to
talk about but they don't even listen to
podcast right and they just do a podcast
because it may know what helps our
career I do a podcast cuz i love podcast
dude i did a meet and greet i'm doing
another one I'm going to be in London in
a couple weeks and I was just going to
do a meet-and-greet I mean just go hey
guys I'll be a bar if you went to a
meetup let's all hang out and just
[ __ ] because when I get together
with my fans or whatever we end up just
talking about what we've listened to
right I went and did a podcast i did
when i was in Scotland doing my TV show
and I got these these three guys that
were just like hey man if you're in
Scotland we gotta buy you a beer and I
was like sure i go i'm right by this
castle meet me here at four i love
that's picasa Josh you're in Scotland
right by this kappa that could be any
way is a standard conversation I mcallen
your castle and they say got there and
is so funny this is out like they're
like the five years I seem at the bar go
over and they go
machine I'm again they're like did you
listen to a bobcat on Jose and I was
like oh no are you kidding me in that
immediately I'm like I got I got three
hours of a flight back home that I get
to kill listening to a podcast feeling
oh dude we've done that I when I was in
Australia last year I just said a little
like hey let's do a meet up and go to a
movie and a handful of comedy Filner's
fans were like they were like we're
going to I did two of them one was a
group of them we all went to go see this
movie another one this couple was like
oh we wanted to take you to a movie so
they took me to like an arthouse they're
all like we don't want to take you to
like some cineplex and see a shitty
transformer like we saw like Michael
Fassbender's Hamlet you know their life
took me to the bows like sots because
whatever your mattress it's not mass
fall talking like a dick around a castle
and a weird outfit in Scotland I China
Vietnam whatever I Shakespeare get a
both about all the grease I've taken
when we meet the fans to it feels like
all right we already know them wherever
they start to talk about movies and
stuff as always it's all yeah with us
it's always like that always want to get
into a movie too yeah yeah that's the
end which I loved your like after shows
like I want to take your time but what
did you think I'm like no no no I want
that was really like that is the
translatable dialogue you have like for
me right now everyone was to talk about
weight loss about Tom Segura about is we
fled that big fat shaming thing we did
Jose podcast we did jose podcast and I
mean not to like disrespect traditional
media but like Jose podcast has more
eyes on it than anything we know or more
ears and eyes on it that anything we
know of in traditional media than we've
ever had in our entire lives we didn't
get the tonight show like The Tonight
Show wasn't around for us like we didn't
get that opportunity through the way the
Johnny Carson weather at you come to the
couch and it blows up your career ya and
now you do Rogan and you watched it's
the broken bump you will just watch your
numbers spike and then you watch all
your shows sellout and its people who
have listened to you talk drunk and high
for six hours in last week and they're
like and they know everything about you
they know everything and i don't know i
think it's question turn my phone off no
it's it's the coolest thing and that's
like why bill burr's new special is out
this is by the way there is no
competition anymore who gives a [ __ ]
it's a great [ __ ] special rappers new
specials out and it is on netflix it's
airing right now all things comedy
president and probably funder of our
parties are hurt he's our wonder they go
well anyway but uh writer what ya
underwriting all things comedy he is his
new special walked your way out I
haven't seen it I just watched it on the
treadmill it's fantastic nice [ __ ]
fantastic there's two bit like you know
like obviously you have a refined palate
for comedy so like part of it you like a
guy I know where we're going like you're
figuring it out but there's a man
there's a couple bits that are burbot
exclusively where I am [ __ ] howling
going like I didn't see that angle holy
[ __ ] he's and he know he's he's someone
that challenges himself in inside the
artistry of comedy where I feel every
hour he tries to do more stuff different
than he did the year before right so
it's not just like a political rant or
misogynistic you know take a funny
angled take on misogyny it this one
there's a lot of like great character
play and like storytelling i was really
thats clucking phenomenal so check it
out on netflix i don't need to tell you
guys i'm sure you guys will watch them
anyway but i just thought it to mota
that's the cool thing now is in this
this era of like a lot of people are
making comedy specials and it's like
with the medium well with the technology
being so affordable people are doing
really cool inventive things like I love
that kira soltanovich and Ali Wong did
specials pregnant yeah had with babies
and no kuro urinated and repairs
throughout that special I did you know
that yeah
she's pregnant so the baby's pressing on
her bladder if she did forgot to pee
before she got on stage and it was like
screw it and just peed her pants she
weren't black pants I thought that was
great I thought I haven't seen alleys by
no alleys very sweet person and I've
seen her murder at the store you know
but I haven't seen it it's like well
that's the thing I like what what like
traditional network would have let that
United mean look at me Oh Brendan
special meal bread mike is phenomenal
yeah phenomenal to the point right
whatever I would say like I kind of
would say like I like to stand up in the
one-liners to that personal [ __ ] I
[ __ ] move me and I was like I was a
great call because it is it could get
weird so he has the other two Mike's man
I did texted in them and I was like you
are your specials fantastic i love this
i love this part of this business and I
don't know if it's la it like the New
York you know guys are ballbusting
competitive but man in LA I don't see
anyone bickering and he's our marijuana
maybe well well I think it's the Padre
doesn't hurt yes I think the podcasting
has really helped that because I've seen
some comics that are just in traditional
media and I and I hang out and I know
them or whatever and they're not in
podcasting because those of us in
podcasting like yeah we'll all take a
traditional media gig I'm not going to
say no to the money but we all know like
our hearts are in this and and and it's
like it's like I remember distinctly I
maybe we talked about this or didn't
when you're on my podcast but I remember
when I first moved out to LA and I would
hang out at the improv and I'd see you
and Doug like down at the corner of the
bar just talking and I was so scared to
go down and be like say hi and i thought
like cuz I didn't know you guys I knew
of you guys and I wanted to be friends
but I didn't know how to then BAM also
we gonna podcast you're like Dave
Anthony him anyone come on my show I
would have never been able to bump into
Dave Anthony we pass wooden crosses if
they be fair in person still kind of
off-putting yeah when we go up the
comedian's afterward thing I don't know
I have met so many comics because now
there's a reason because before
podcasting be like hey I don't know you
you want to just talk for an hour yeah
I'd never take Titus can i pick your
mind about storytelling for one hour
Moby's the pentagram I got a kid like
leave me alone over tonight can I listen
you take on politics until you have to
pee and now it's like I've gone up to so
many comics and said hey I got to get
you on the show oh yeah and I like just
saw them do a set you didn't know what a
party it's like conversation starters
now because I felt that way too when
you're in a like others a commune that
kind of like you feel awkward going up
to them and talking to yeah now you're
like hey I guess this podcast want to go
on it and then you know it was easier
now i know you know i was just watching
the unusual suspects and I'm like
there's a young kevin Pollak you spent
on our podcast bring his on that we're
doing his own saturday like i watch the
Cubs in Game seven World Series at his
house and I'm like did you email us
yesterday about the festival gay I mean
okay Tech Dave okay okay yeah yeah yeah
look I cool oh you're the best i think
that's cool i'm gonna push it i'm gonna
move my stuff around but i think that's
really cool it like are we announcing
our first act for the fastest cool no
but i'll tell you right now man never
like right now I've never seen the
biggest names and comedies are moving
around their schedules and I'm [ __ ]
them that's a statement right there well
then it's our sixth year you know and I
think we were a lot of work and we're
very proud of the fact that we've
established this way only one night
Melville will do they believe establish
a relationship with them you know we
have relationships with these shows and
it's funny that you know some people
went to that other festival and I get it
that festival was paying shows and
whatever that's your network and then
you know podcasters and fans were like
it just didn't have the same yeah I
don't even know the other one was
doesn't matter no no I got offered a gig
at one of them but I was like I was like
I my show if it's gonna be like if I'm
gonna ask my friends to do it it's a
paid gig I'm have to get my friends
money I can't just talk at the money
yeah it's like no one wants to hear me
speak alone especially do for a living
oh my god I don't know what their me
speak alone I'll be in Lexington all
week on the off-broadway so let's start
the show that's already i'll let you out
movies will do it all right Chris Oh
Resident Evil the final chapter Oh what
is it final is it well
what everything going on it really felt
like an interesting documentary yeah
really all right so this is like just
over the world go look like after Trump
yeah yeah this is like you know I think
this is a teaching a survival skills
really think that we're going to need
this information we should see it how to
it's an educational yes I educational
documentary so you know Neil and I went
to see it and there was a bunch of other
people in the theater look like they
went into the wrong film so but Neil and
I knew what we were getting into and
I've seen all these movies I've played
all the games and I will say the final
chapter resident evil no better or worse
than any of the others I've seen a
couple of them and they're they're crazy
fun you don't want to just a girls on a
motorcycle shooting rabid dogs or
whatever okay Becca Phil no little bit
yeah yeah she is the [ __ ] she's got a
couple of kids I think she's in her 40
count it looks amazing on her my wife
her you know her husband said I'm it was
a real family movie or husband was the
director and their kid is like the
computer quote red queen who you know is
all finger but now family that yes makes
a post survival horror movies yeah
together exactly because they're
planning for the future so my question
you Chris do you does the Mancini family
now have a plan in place as the result
of things we would know because the key
word in that sentence was now we've had
it in place for many oh yeah we haven't
managed to strategies yes does that tie
I I would joke on them and telling on
stage cuz the joke is a learned a very
valuable lesson the other day never take
a look I'll with diarrhea in your bed
sheesh it's my wife starts yelling she's
crying the dogs trying to eat it mother
kid labs Archie [ __ ] in her pants and I
realized this is my field team 6 this is
how we're going to handle an apocalypse
you know it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] show you
know what's weird if that was like the
opening scene to this film and then
zombie taming
so this movie is absolutely hilarious i
hope it makes money to pay off the
lawsuits for the poor people who were
injured and killed during the film what
happened this is old school 80's movie
yeah this is like killing people
rejection crashed a motorcycle needing
to have her arm amputated and then a
crew member died while filming when a
Humvee he was standing there wasn't
secured and crushed him Oh God go well
now that bums me out yeah yeah and this
is like God like a dog's purpose Bradley
is brutal I don't know if I can watch
this oh I know what's weird is too is
this like this it's not like it's the
first resident evil movie you think by
now like we should know how to shoot
these without anyone getting hurt now I
will say the action and cut the budget
on the safety cord yeah that's what it
I'll tell you these movies are not cheap
to make when you look at these I hear
they prompts a narwhal away haha Bert
Kreischer calm ladies and gentlemen so
like you're watching this movie and you
know there's a ton of movie put into it
and it's got everything you want in a
crazy action horror movie it's got
zombies monsters giant tanks with
carrots on them you know hot women in
slow motion kicking zombie app it's one
of those movies where this is what it is
and nothing's going to change your mind
whether you're going to like it or not
and it because it's so that the story is
ridiculous it's barely there the the
editing is sometimes so confusing the
scenes don't even match but no one cares
so it's really about all these zombies
getting obliterated and monsters but I
will say this they took the horror a
little more seriously pneus when there
were some jump scares where he jumped
out of your seat a couple times oh I
hate that so yeah there was definitely
ID then I'm uncomfortable the rest of
the media haha sure getting an anxiety
attack that's what I'm gonna want to
watch the ring i was like i'm getting an
anxiety attack this is not what a look
at ring is a tough one yeah that's why I
sit in the back row uh-huh so I can see
everybody and all the exits don't even
get me started yeah I got a panic attack
in the ring and I started thinking how
do I know some of those have a bag of
gasoline gonna pour it over me a light
meal fire I was like oh my god
wrong see now when I sit movie theaters
I gotta be exported on I almost OSI a
gasoline yeah I look for the pinch zone
I look for where the single shooter is
going to come in right and I get seats
far away from that place so that when he
starts shooting I'll at least in the
back corner like I really look I get
seats like that now that's how [ __ ]
crazy I am and by the way that's why I
can enjoy zombie movies movies because
I'm so OCD in such a hypochondriac that
even when they get a little cut the head
off in blood splatters I'm like good any
get in their mouth like yeah well as
this is the kind of movie to where it's
like you just put all that aside or like
wait is that you know they're they're
dragging somebody behind on a giant tank
and then there's an army of zombies
following them because its bait and like
some crazy crazy [ __ ] but also stuff
that like makes no sense like like the
story and also there's like well that
guy why is he killing all his own men
are done does he need them to run the
tank like really like really crazy like
random nonsensical things so it says
final chapter but there is a TV series
in the works and really we will see if
you know there will be another one
because these movies do not make that
much money here however overseas they
make a fortune hard to find budget
information on this movie so I mean it
well I mean where would you put it 20
million no no this one's a huge huge
budget do you really think that more
than 70 million I think it's in that
range for sure because my secret movie
that I watched was cross 70 million why
don't know where that movie that money
went and you're moving but this one I
could see worth of zombie and a giant
burned out thing and giant winged
monsters pulling up trucks so there's a
there's a lot of crazier but this was
not a cheap movie to make for sure and
really I really I would easily put it at
that and so they did they just make it
worldwide that's what they make it well
that's where they make the money now one
of the places obviously makes a lot of
money if Japan because that's where the
the video game is made now I will say
this if you're a resident evil fan the
the latest game just came out near the
time of this movie release and the
latest games supposed to be
absolutely terrifying like it's more
like a your you wake up you don't know
where you are you're in this horrible
mansion like the Louisiana bayou and
it's a crazy like x-files mutant family
that's there that's keeping you prisoner
and trapped and you have to literally
get out save and save your own life so
but that's the kind of thing where
you're being stalked through a weird
mansion by like a bunch of mutant
hillbillies so far a move for video
games right now oh yeah that is the
pac-man creator died yeah so so this
movie I will say this it's it's one of
those movies of like if you've enjoyed
the movies in the series you'll enjoy
this one if you haven't enjoyed them
this movie will not change your mind all
right but it's definitely if you like
action and some you know with like a
real action and hard together it's
really is it's non-stop action this one
they really said all right this the last
one we're going to just make it pretty
much start to finish crazy action with
monsters and zombies all right ever
think that those directors at some point
we'll go and then 70 million dollars we
can make this movie or I could make
every movie I ever thought of making I
said it all the time when I see these
giant 150 dollar million dollar movies
that aren't that great i always go I
could make how many like 35 million
dollar movies that are the coolest thing
don't you think studio execs must think
about that too where it's like all right
well I can spend 100 million on this or
I could make a hundred 1 million dollar
movies I mean I I they need to I mean
that will the studio's the big studios
are like no and Fulton tenfold temple
make the 150 million dollar one that
brings in a half a billion dollars or a
billion dollars in overall revenue in
[ __ ] toys and right you know they've
got some deal with Burger King or
whatever the [ __ ] that's why that's
where they're thinking yeah it's the
only industry where a movie making a
million or two million dollar profit is
like that yes another business like if
you had a law firm that had a
two-million-dollar or any business that
is a two million dollar profit anyone
involved it'd be like you [ __ ] like no
homework do you know how hard two
million dollars is to make you ever make
40 grand a week yes I'm so tough that's
a lot that's a lot of money that's a lot
of money ha well two million dollars
over the span of a lifetime
how do you make them a lot of TGS yeah
so yeah so Neil and I it was a guilty
pleasure right we enjoyed some of the uh
no one's coming on board for the new
ready to tackle you either have been on
this thing right here whenever on sorry
I saw requiem for the American Dream now
this is the interview with noam chomsky
it is a documentary I saw it on netflix
i think he came out about a year ago but
they've been giving it they've been
pressing it maybe I've just been
watching a lot of the whole system is
broken documentary so natalie she was
like oh you're going yes adjusted for
gram yeah this is really interesting
what they suggest for you and what they
suggest for me what do they suggest
about they suggest anything with like
muscle building the ultra marathon
runners died too young i watch the heath
ledger it's not even a real documentary
it's just Chariots of Fire no no no
chariots of fire was on there anyone
commies everyone's comedy specials right
and then but I don't get like good stuff
I'm like I feel like I need to like
revamp my my netflix cuz what they're
sending me is just you got to be careful
I gave I saw super high me and I was
like oh I'm in this so I just gave it
five stars so then like you might like
Freck and every batch stoner rock every
[ __ ] rasta love or whatever just
again anything about black people burn
you love black people do you want to be
black that's what they'll do yeah so I
saw this movie because I've been
watching a lot of political docs and on
the wine I can't imagine this event
happened unless um for the last hour uh
who knows check you turn on your phone
I'm sure somebody got fired or the
blocked or the results you really want
to know for me the upside of the Trump
victory has made me like I'm going to
start paying more attention not that I
wasn't paying attention before but now
I'm like really paying attention and the
more you pay attention for me the more
I'm like oh this is why i'm an
independent i'm a left-leaning
independent but this is like the whole
system noam chomsky if you're familiar
with them you'll probably already know
not he's worth reading or watching this
documentary goes into why how America
has become just this corporate machine
and it's like you know he goes back to
like James Madison writing stuff saying
the you know the dirty huddled masses
shouldn't have that much of a say and
how democracy is they've sort of faked
it you know and they break it down the
filmmaker does an excellent job because
this is no we talked about this a lot on
the show it's the type of documentary
all you're doing is interviewing one guy
so that can be that could be really
boring so the filmmaker does an
excellent job you will be rule do my god
but he doesn't just it's not it's not
nonsensical b-roll just to cut away to
he breaks my resident evil be wrong
there's no demon dog no Chomsky talks
about his socialist views he he does
great stuff that he breaks down
Chomsky's like basically his thesis into
ten parts and goes into like here's how
they've done it here's how the
corporation's have you know they they
fought it's a lot of history to he goes
into the like there was labor riots in
the 20s and 30s big companies the big
like Rockefeller type barons just dudes
who owned apple orchards I just saw a
documentary about a guy who owned apple
orchards who would lower the RIT wages
and oh yeah keep going I'm sorry no no
but that's yeah that's a great point
because that's what was going down is is
is so and they show there was like they
hire the Pinkerton to just go fund of
his fights and the cops would come down
and just nightstick the [ __ ] out of
people back then and then World War
check then yeah now it's all peaceful
what he talked about the militarization
of the police he talks about now today
only seven percent of the american
workforce is unionized because they have
tried to get rid of unions he talks
about like how the banking industry that
wrong now seven percent look at us look
at us comics there's we should have a
[ __ ] Union we should have union we
should have a podcaster union could have
all kinds of you I mean like it's it's
it's unbel--
she talks about how the banking crisis
right that Bush and Obama handled and he
said what they did is is they become the
regulator's that's why none of them went
to jail Obama didn't ask any like Nobel
laureate economist hey how do we fix
this those Wall Street [ __ ] that
created it they got to write the
regulatory fee is I want to see that's
not drives me nuts and this I'm
definitely not going off on a political
rant but what bothers me these days is
that both sides of media are either
liberal or conservative there's no one
the middle just saying oh yeah this rich
Muslim travel ban is actually it's not
that big of a deal 109 people out of the
300,000 flu or or hey that you know date
these are this was implemented no one's
telling me the true so I can't like
there was that lady who organized the
woman's March I forget her name but they
said I think was Linda from Hawaii her
Nate was it she from oh I I believe so I
wish she was Muslim right um but she was
she was Muslim me she was like pro
Sharia law Sharia law and so then the
Liberals are just like you can't believe
the Conservatives and then the current
interpreters are like she's a terrorist
and then you're then you look up Shariah
law and you're like you she is for it
you're like wow that it's pretty
aggressive that she'd be a woman
marching with women's rights but for
Sharia law then I can't find anyone just
telling me oh yeah she is however like I
can't find just the truth well what this
documentary is very it goes into a great
point of like there isn't conservative
and liberal media its corporate yeah
they literally it's there just and one
of the things he talks about is the
design of the corporate media and
creating the liberal and conservative
media is to divide us because if we're
all divided you have state blue state
then we won't turn and look oh these
corporate [ __ ] are the one that are
[ __ ] all of us I mean it's it's such
an end but it but so Noam Chomsky is
pretty his thoughts are pretty heady and
pretty dense so the filmmaker does an
excellent job of breaking them down like
into ten sections and then using really
interesting beer Oh Land
archival footage showing so as no miss
speaking you're getting a visual like
it's visually being reinforced all ok
and this is the kind of [ __ ] I need to
watch you should watch this I'm gonna
watch this because this is this is
something where I go I just need to hear
other ideas well I remember when I was
in college we had one of the executives
I think from CBS come and speak to the
class and he said the way it all broke
down was pretty much it's like well
here's our entertainment but news is our
responsibility which meant that was our
responsibility to give you the news and
not necessarily turn a profit it didn't
matter the other shows were making a
profit news was as a broadcaster our
responsibility to give people what was
going on in the truth that went away
when all the corporation's realized know
every single thing needs to make a
profit in clio news and then that was
the beginning of the end that you saw in
that movie network when everything
became for-profit and now all news is
just entertainment for profit that's all
it is done I really think though if
somebody started a news channel where
the whole thing was just news I think it
would do really well let's they're out
there and this is the thing I've been
finding to is I'm finding other news
sources like the intercept and literally
but a guardian and BBC are really great
Guardian BBC are great to intercept the
economist you got it be great to have
one here in this country yeah right no
but you think I could find I couldn't
find a I couldn't even find a slanted
review an unplanted review of bill burr
like I looked at I would collect on this
thing and Huffington Post gave him like
a cold shoulder nod that he has a
special out and I was like oh clearly
because bill doesn't say things humming
post agrees with and so you're like if
you go to it will like depending on what
kind of cable you have you can get BBC
america which is excellent you can get
NHK which is the NHK world which is from
Japan its english-speaking and their
their news you watch you watch BBC
america or NHK and they just tell a
story there's not a flag-waving or in a
big like crisis thing graphic that's not
crisis will go the crisis a never
flashing crisis logo
then when I start reading like Glenn
Greenwald and people like and chris
hedges I'm like oh they're really
breaking it down because they're just
like there's not Republican Democrat
there's one party yeah it's the bank
party it's the money party it's like big
oil banks and big military no I miss the
good old days yeah I really do I really
miss when we knew where enemy was yeah
once the commies and we were like don't
you don't want to be remember my dad
none of my dad's and it's kind of
everyone's gonna hate my dad but he
wouldn't let me play soccer she's like
that's a pinko commie sport you can play
baseball that's an American sport I'm I
was like first grade and I was like like
why I'm and then it just put it in my
head football basketball baseball about
what I was allowed to play cricket come
on Chris get on board clearly let me
play yeah no drinking no son of Mines
going to be a highlight player dude
highlight was huge in Tampa huge in
Tampa the Tampa my butt motor my best
friend Tony Hernandez every time we seem
to go I'm Sonia has mondays from some
pie so it's worth watching and if you
want to get more information about
what's really going on because I think a
lot of people are feeling that
frustration about like well I can't
trust and and we did an episode we're
going to we did a spoiler up of the
documentary 13th that we're going to
release later this week do with with
John Updike from open primaries that and
he brought up a great point he's like if
I don't trust if you don't trust me I
can hold up a piece of paper that's a
white sheet of paper and say this is a
white sheet of paper and you'll go I
don't [ __ ] trust you so I don't even
know what you're showing me if you know
what I'm saying and I think that's
what's happened because the media is so
how can you trust the media and and
they're not in my opinion they're not
liberal conservative I mean they gave
Trump 5 billion dollars of free
advertising during the campaign yeah and
and they're not doing they haven't been
doing your jobs for years and now it too
and you know it he told me what can play
them and they were like okay I mean I
saw them cut away from a Bernie Sanders
speech to go to an empty podium or Trump
was going to speak because he's better
rate
Thanks oh oh yeah I've been like so so
so when you hear that it's like I don't
[ __ ] trust this media and you watch
who's buying their ad time it's like
look who's buying ads on all these
things and like you know Richard group
via via alpha yeah pharmaceutical
companies old people products like it's
unbelievable in like Rachel Maddow make
seven million dollars a year you know
like none of them are just least like
she should be a vessel for information
right not like a like a pungent as well
entertainer they're all entertainers
sean hannity rachel maddow they're all
[ __ ] i watched sean hannity interview
Trump and I was like hungover I was on
the road and I was howling laughing I
honestly I mean I I can't stop giggling
at this president because he says things
that are so unofficial even when Barack
Obama comes out and says I don't like
the fact that you did this Muslim ban
Barack Obama don't even say that he goes
I think that all Americans in like like
this windy we be I'm a Tom Brady
quarterbacked kind of way and then
here's Trump like Allen Iverson [ __ ]
thug life [ __ ] yeah keep them out of
our time you know it's like so I who
you're not supposed to talk like that
it's so weird to hear president talk
like that they're bad people they're
really bad well bad and I that what
that's the thing of a distrust of
everything is why some people resonated
with him I don't agree with him on just
about 99% of what he says but I
understand why people go everyone's been
[ __ ] lying to me the government's
been lying to met the press has been
lying he's not he said he was gonna ban
Muslims and build a wall you think they
do it tell you something that guy's
doing exactly what he said he's gonna do
a little refreshing yes so we see
someone come in and go yeah should we
take him literally now yeah it was being
serious am I talking yeah he was saying
stuff and I was like building a wall
sure sure he's like no bucket building
it so i retweeted somebody oh my god
this tweet was hilarious it was the head
Trump's tweet about how they have to
keep all the bad dudes the really bad
dudes out of Adam somebody retweeted
Christ you're the president not a ninja
turtle and that's resonate but but
like this going back to requiem for a
dream with noam chomsky's on netflix and
it's really worth like it'll peel back
the onion I saw this great interview
with chris hedges and he's like well if
Trump doesn't get into an arms race or
really start ramping up the war the
military-industrial complex will get him
impeached and you're like wow because
that's what's really going on the Koch
brothers just came out to say they're
not in favor of Trump's Muslim ban it
must be [ __ ] up their oil money
somewhere like I don't trust any of ya
now that I think about it all these
things he said he was going to do I
guarantee you he had insight we're
blowing like hey if I say if I say I'm
gonna do this that means these companies
get to kind of pony up and start making
money off some [ __ ] that I'm saying
right and that's why they were like
getting behind my gap build a wall I
make cinder blocks yes what would the
check it out it's interesting so let's
go go to I wanted to talk about hidden
figures again I know we've talked about
it a bunch of times I just wanted to
mention one thing because we saw it as a
family all four of us one this is it by
the way this is an example of why I suck
as a human being just because I because
I saw I saw it the trailer and then I
was like oh my god I don't know you
should like yeah I get it flexible can
do math I get it like like what yeah I
don't know if that was the reaction they
were looking for the trailer that was
that that's what's wrong with me there's
a movie called the salesman that is a
trailer that I just saw and I'm like I
was like oh this looks good and i click
on I gotta [ __ ] read it nevermind and
then and so like I'm the I'm that I am
that um why they make rather than evil
for right i bought my wife saw it my
wife's like this movie is phenomenal my
wife's told my daughters and they're
like it's the best movie we've ever seen
and I was like what why can't I just see
three black women as the leads and go
god I'm really excited about this I just
don't go here here's what i would do I
would just blame the trailer editor you
didn't I just go see the movie anyway
Mike oh yeah that's really more say
maybe I'm a racist horrible human being
maybe I let me tell you something it's
the reason they
Matt Damon on the in in the movie the
wall because let me tell you something
the guys like me in this country that
fee chow yun-fat or don't even know mr.
Miyagi they see someone for this just
asian and the thing and go oh this must
been made in asia it's like Jesus I
don't we need canneries in 47 Ronin yeah
yeah there we go see that's where my
brain goes is I go I go Matt Damon's
that I'll go see it but it is the it is
like it's like if you know if you're if
it's your 70 million dollars you know
that you're going to invest in the movie
like are you gonna roll the dice from
some unknown Asian actor that kills it
really great but half the population is
going to go Hosanna dango we funded in
China well yeah here's an external
example so like that movie The Wall what
china now has because they've had a
virgin as researchers at an exploding
middle class because of the
manufacturing they now have three or
four times as many movie screens as we
do in America because there's money
people have money to go to the movies
now movies like the wall they put Matt
Damon in it for the American trailer and
in the Chinese trailer he's barely in it
are you serious oh yeah see that's what
I like to see I like that I like mention
it up I'm not genuinely a racist but I
am when it's my money and if I'm gonna
go see something I'm gonna see this [ __ ]
I want to see you know like I look for
stupid like hahaha I put Tom Cruise in
another mission impossible I'll [ __ ]
there oh yeah mommy impossible oh yeah
yeah that looks phenomenal yeah togekiss
okie boat about home figures what was
the one of the ones we got the tweets
from the fans it goes when we're talking
about the trailer I can't believe you
guys must show me the mummy yeah that's
great so so anyway hitting figures I'll
tell you I really liked this movie
sometimes you forget that Kevin Costner
is a good actor because he's done a
bunch of garbage but you know he was
really good in it I love the story and I
love the fact that we could see it as a
family of an 11 year old in an eight
year olds and now the adriel got a
little bit of bored in between but he
liked the science and the rockets and
all that stuff and you know my daughter
is old enough to really understand this
racist happened you know this this
happens is there was a colored weathers
got yeah this is
we talked about it afterwards like was
that that really haven't said yeah that
was real and what I loved about it is
because after we saw the 13th which was
such a brutally you know you know
documentary it was like shocking and
brutal but this movie was the same
subject racism what's this one's my
clear take my favorite this is a
documentary about its nominated for four
best it's got an Oscar nomination it's
about basically how the America has used
a loophole in the 13th amendment to
imprison more black men than anyone else
right makes sense yeah they're certain I
mean not to derail you but like to
justify my my liberal heart is like when
you go I when you do jury duty all you
see is young black males going through
the system and it's not set up to them
to succeed not it's set up to be
confusing and there's people that are
just getting their job done or like look
just take the plea bargain you'll be in
for six months it won't be that bad they
don't realize is hanging go in for six
months that [ __ ] goes on it's really
hard to stay out of the system once that
happens well yeah I mean it's it's the
thing of like a white teenager is three
times less likely to go to jail for
being busted with weed they're having a
black teenager it's just unlike and the
documentary 13th goes into yeah this
that started post-civil war how this how
they've been it's it's it's a it's a
really you watch where at reading for a
dream Bert and then watch 13 um well
Jane Doe and Serkis was on like Netflix
um yeah today those on the top thing oh
I'm [ __ ] in those on the banner and
this is the kind of thing to where it's
such a brutal documentary but it's a
very it's a very good one but you know I
wouldn't show my kids that I mean
they're they're not at the age is that
they could process it properly now you
can make now even well the kids you
can't hide them from the truth that's
not what it is what it is is if you show
them images and ideas they're not ready
for they won't process it properly we're
as a movie like hidden figures you could
see the racism granted studio polish we
talked about then for sure but it it's
almost like an entry level like yeah
this is part of our history this really
happened but what I really liked about
it was that it was a hopeful message
that you know yes you can protest racism
and you
move civil rights forward by marching
and doing all these things but you can
also move it toward by being good at
maths and the other ways and they have
that conversation in the movies there's
different ways to move civil rights
forward which I thought was a really
cool and hopeful message and my daughter
loved that we all loved it even my son
who got bored in the middle east he
liked it too well that's a good point of
it because we talked about the studio
polished last week of Maryland rank up
and that was a sort of thing that I you
know I wanted more grittiness right but
but you're right in that is if the
studio polish of the hidden figures gets
more people to get it and understand it
be it kids or just people that let's say
they're not well versed in history or
they're like it that really happened yet
did like these women were treated this
way and they helped the space program if
the studio polish gets more people to
watch it and open up to that and then
all the work that's a good idea what was
it rated you do you remember how to get
EG yes that's all it was exactly yeah
and it was wasn't the kind of marketing
thing wears like oh we need to PG 13 so
people go see it this was a deliberate
PG movie and i thought it was brilliant
yeah exact way that this movie should
have been this will be a movie i'll end
up watching on a plane they'll catch me
off guard and i'll be drunk and i'll be
sobbing whoa yeah and everyone's like
whoo did he commit a hate crime that
happened to me in fault their stars
flying back from japan i was like crying
it so in the morning joy joy yeah joy
did that to you i am pouring pouring if
she walks out of that Texas hotel
sobbing on a plane and then and then you
get me with more the sucker punch of it
where it is she didn't know that she'd
be running her own multi man I'm like oh
my god yeah I also saw room 237 but you
know what I'm going to talk about this
we talked to an fournisseur I'm gonna
talk about it on the bonus thing in the
iphone app okay um but Burt you saw lady
in the water yeah it caught me off guard
look I I see Paul Giamatti and I see
Bryce Howard and I go I never saw this
movie and I hung out with M night
Shyamalan and he wanted me to do his
schwalm oween schwa Moline is like a big
of any as in philly and he's a really
cool guy who's really cool guy and I and
I have always loved what he does but I I
haven't really watched everything he
does hahaha so I just loved a good one
yeah and so and i'm a sucker i'm a
sucker for like a mathematical rhythmic
movie like a movie where there's we've
got to figure things out like we're
solving riddles throughout it and so I
was I was uh I loved it I loved it even
everyone is then immediately what I do
is I get really nervous so immediately
what I do is I go to Wikipedia and I
start watching like reading what happens
like I'll tell me what happens i'm going
to read the next sentence okay okay
that's not too bad and so I watch it I
read it and then I go and then I go
really you cliff note you're moving
except look I do have with all my movies
because it maybe they make me nervous it
makes me nervous to not know what's
going to happen sometimes so like any
thriller I always go to the cliff note
okay and so so you have storytelling
anxiety yeah I'm like because I couldn't
do because it's there's like is there a
prescription this is eight minutes left
in the movie and she gets attacked by
the damn Scouts called stunt whatever
it's called the water monster the boy
yet though the thing and I go wait how's
it gonna end so I'm like I'm like I
can't I can't know that she dies this
can't be how this movie ends and so I
flipped doing it good oh okay all the
father what lopsided bodybuilder the guy
that just worked one arm he's the
guardian so he's the healer oh oh that's
their the the coven or whatever i don't
know but i don't really pay attention
much a movie but what I loved what I
loved is how much really that's why you
like it well that Nova can limit but now
I've read critic reviews and I'm like
and they're like he's saying that that
he's saying ultimately that he plays
this big part in this movie and he's
saying basically his literary works will
save the world and that's why no one
could stomach it because it seemed like
he was saying in the movie IM m night
shyamalan i will change the world with
my writings and
like did I start loving those moments
I'm like oh you will change the world at
night and then and then they're like and
then they're like we couldn't get past
the fact that he made a film critic he
made a film critic be a [ __ ] complete
and total jerk and I thought I was like
oh my god how great is that film critics
hate this because the film critic is a
[ __ ] he's arrogant he's pompous and he
gets murdered brutally against his
better judgment and so I I gave it two
thumbs up life interesting because so
split just came out January 20s which is
his latest movie which he said that's
amore guess what's he gonna say yeah of
course I haven't seen it but here's
something interesting it at a 10 million
dollar budget it did 40 million dollars
its opening weekend and to date it's
done 77 million dollars that's still
alive million more lady in the water
being I don't know if you know this
self-funded so but in his own money be
putting his own money and I think like
it might be we might have a resurgence
because I just say that every movie but
no I mean what is doing all the box
office his other ones too haven't done
that the last couple and he's had some
some ones that have tanked and again I
mean that's compared to budget vs growth
that's actually what's really good
that's fantastic and split looks cool to
me it does who's the actor in it it's um
he's mentioned to me for these macro
James McAvoy he said he's phenomenal in
it well he's playing yeah he's playing
like 15 different people or something we
were talking the girl that dead he
kidnaps the girl from Morgan yeah she
looks really cool and creepy and
everything looks the whole thing looks
really super creepy I found I found him
fascinating to enter because I get to
interview him for a little bit only but
not too much but we were to impressing
and Steve and all we got dressed in his
yeah yeah and I was like I was like how
do you call about story because like for
those who don't know I'm a ver I'm a big
storytelling comic art I tell stories on
stage man the coolest things are when a
story like when you lay like a like a
ton of red herring but like a little
line of a bit that's going to be very
useful at the end of your story like
these little these little I little
droplets
and for me I developed story on stage
and I you've got to figure those out and
sometimes it's just luck of the draw you
change it up one night but he goes you
know sixth sense had nothing to do with
ghosts when he first started it it was
just it was just a story about about
this guy going through a divorce and
then I was like what and he's like so I
find his process to be fascinating and
then I and then I go I can't help but
appreciate all those little droplets you
put into this movie the lady in the
water and I understand it could look
like you know to the most people they're
like it's a little heavy-handed but it's
a little obscure and but like I was like
I [ __ ] love it like I love that [ __ ]
like like I'm the idiot that when when
when the movie about the aliens happened
remember the one with mel gibson behind
signs I'm the idiot that one go they go
he's they're allergic to water and then
you hear the voice over swing and I
start getting chills I go swing away so
please realize it's like not knowing
that yeah dummy that's exactly what's
gonna happen eventually you're gonna
kill them here is water everywhere holy
the waters everywhere you're gonna be a
fullback he doesn't as well that's where
the poison isn't killing us like I'm
like realizing all the same time um I am
that window where I go bleep why is the
wives the crippled walking street oh my
god the centrosomes ain't like I'm that
guy and so I appreciate like I say what
did you do with the end up ran into the
eighth which one was that Charlton
Heston 10 I didn't ever watched it clean
I saw the bubble burgundy me a favor
watch the original one and take yourself
watching the ending really yes um I has
the only there's a video online if you
want to watch it is very entertaining
it's me watching the ending of Time
Traveler's Wife with Opie from Opie and
Anthony and sharad small that movie
makes me cry every time and that and I
love time travel I'm obsessed with on
top oh yeah Dave Anthony said I got to
watch time crunch should it's the best
time-traveling movie ever like time
travel movies because i love the math I
love the riddle of it I love that it
figures it's all a self out and that you
got to keep going back and then you know
like I love that I wanted to do a
time-traveling sitcom so bad
had about a guy who every time we went
to this one bar and drank he did he'd go
time travel but he'd be drunk and then
he'd go and time travel into like
Mississippi in the 60s and he'd have to
help Martin Luther King you know but he
was hammered the whole time and he was
the reason that Martin Luther King had
gave the ice skate I have a dream speech
right like it like it was like moments
in history but uh and then I go I could
just do it travel channel show all right
well that's so the hearing him talk
about lady in the water make I'm now
kind of want to go see split oh I'm
definitely being split up Lucy yeah I
want to go see split one of us should I
so you're just a girl see it you're
gonna you're not going to resident evil
all right he's our resident evil I'll go
see split that's fair all right let's
talk about some trailer this is my
passion yeah you told me this this is
it's a problem I haven't I'm not joking
it isn't it is and it for any safe place
here bird why are you I a safe place
coming Filner dunes you know exactly how
this can destroy one of your days and i
cannot get off them and and i just went
in yesterday on a lark and I was like oh
it's almost like a I like you know the
feeling of when you get done press your
like wet fur I haven't jacked off today
like a new your heart is excited like I
have that about trailers going oh my god
I haven't listed trailers in like ten
days I bet there's new ones what pisses
me off is that they dropped all the new
trailers today all the new trailers just
came out today and yeah and I'm already
enough away but the one I saw that I
like the most that you guys wanted to
bring up with cat fight yes that movie I
am so on board with this l yeah there
are the funniest trailers and you're
just like it's two women beating the
[ __ ] out like straight punch right to
the Fela just not like old school like
70s cop bar brawl knockout type of
fighting yeah yeah good watch like it is
it was welcome Gretna coma for two years
well they're two friends at high school
yeah didn't like each other right for
they knew each other in high school
and ones at the bottom of her life ones
at the top and they meet at a party of
the ones at the top they get to a fifth
fight in the stairwell and their lives
shift drastically because of that 19
right and then after the ship they come
back and their lives they get to another
fist fight and their life shift again i
love that i almost want it to be where
they keep fighting in like one of those
movies were remember that movie where
every time someone um every time someone
hit got a guy got hurt money would show
up in a pot remember this now there was
a movie where every time he got his wife
beat him up this money would come out
like the magic teapot I think I'm done
like that and so like I remember I love
movies where the violence is just
comical in nature because they need it
so I hope that they have to get like
five more fights right it's interesting
because if the writer director is this
guy a more Turk Turk 02 Kyle okay slow
Marty puzzle in this movie I don't
puffin on American how to get in the
country to shoot it yeah cornville he's
not a bunch of low-budget things like
Richard's wedding summer of blood
applesauce Abby singer-songwriter movies
I personally haven't seen but this
trailer catfight guys go watch the
catfight trailer will post it on the
Facebook page yes it's like I am good
old fired up man hey Alicia Silverstone
and hydro Sandro and Haitian Sandra Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of each other if you're
bummed out that Ronda Rousey's career
isn't going the way you wanted watch
this trailer because it's a knockout
it's [ __ ] knock out yeah yeah and
then what was the other one well Wilson
I saw that thats with Woody Harrelson
yes um I lost interest third of the way
to the trailer it's one of those like
kind of feel goody you know kind of
Arrested Development he's a you know
middle-aged guy never liked nefeli also
noticed he's definitely also so it
really is i mean that is that it must be
the character because you know i don't
know if your kids have friends with
autistic kids or if your kids want a
sticker what but there's a good say
whatever the [ __ ] they're thinking and
that is his character like oh yeah
based on a graphic novel by Daniel
clothes who also wrote the screenplay
and it's directed by Craig Johnson yes
and then he you know he finds out he's a
dad and he tried to get his ex wife and
the daughter together and be a family
and then that's where it like it goes
off the rails and a good way in a funny
way so you want your side you see it for
it or not I'm not I'm more excited about
the catch right no no more excited about
cat fight but the other trailer that I
saw was the one where the guy goes home
and he has to borrow money from his old
friend Daniel cried oh I don't know that
well oh it's such a good trailer and it
reminds me of what there was a movie
called a Chuck and buck there's a long
time ago oh yeah yeah so I might write
yeah Chuck and buck and and i took my
best friend to see except Irwin's like
it's a really good independent film and
apparently Chuck and buck used to suck
and [ __ ] and so that it's about two guys
who are gay growing up and and they and
now the one guy's hiding his sexuality
my best friend the whole time like what
are you trying to tell me but this one
looks like a much funnier version of
this like a much darker funnier version
what's it called I can its wits with the
wha with it looks like a British guy on
the cover in in Daniel cried there's no
cried I don't see that I see owners that
was a pitch it's like a this is a less
gay checking buck it's going to be
halfway down on the apple thing it's a
cartoon drawing of a dude's face anyway
so bad at this what are the trailers
have you seen that you're like look
exciting to you uh well I'll tell you
what my phone pops up because I just had
I just wanted thing I was like oh I saw
the 142 the one with the girl in the
mirror with a knife out like this like
the Traverse Traverse hotel a trip this
is why I don't belong on a [ __ ] mood
right now everyone's losing their mind
going seriously bro you know this is
movies would you go on and a podcast and
not know the names of the fighters you
know the guy with the tattoo on his
stomach yes that's I give that one fight
at one guy here we go here we go uh
Donald cried is the movie okay
Havenhurst is one the one I saw that I
was like
me I don't like scary movies scary
movies really freaked me out um catfight
was [ __ ] phenomenal Slama JAMA too
much heart I was like and I get it and
but and I'm not saying that because
everyone is black in the movie but it's
just like I was like ruin whatever split
looks fantastic Chris fd's ian is the
director and writer of Donald cried it
is interesting it looks really good cool
um and and i think that's it Oh founder
look the founder looks really good we
come I saw that you FL that is it yeah
it's worth seeing I didn't like it as
much as Graham well I'll say this is
what we said if if you're a big Michael
Keaton fan I think you'll probably like
it okay that's what I'll say but you're
there there's a lot of trailers I
haven't seen that I'm really excited to
work all right we covered a bunch yeah
okay I was talk about DVD and blu-ray
blue and the dr Halloween oh [ __ ] hold
on I love it I love it he's actually
what was wrong with me I will watch a
movie like where it's like you know
family Christmas where's all the black
kids come home for the family Christmas
and Danny Donna Donna Donna Danny Glover
yeah is there and and oh you didn't say
nothing about her mashed potatoes like I
won't watch those movies but Madea I
[ __ ] love hahaha like I like the ones
that are like I like that you're a
closet Madea or here I love you I love
Tyler Perry I think he's a [ __ ]
really inspirational amazing dude well
his career like we sure we talked about
it before he's one of the most
successful playwrights and it's worth I
mean we bag on his movie sometimes
because whatever but like the guy said
you know Hollywood told them all
middle-aged black women don't go to the
movies and he wouldn't know you don't
make movies for them yeah so he started
making movies for them and he's [ __ ]
cleaning up and that's what I like I
like that he's making movies for them
sometimes when I see a movie like a
black cast movie words like Kevin Hart
my caps Danny Glover uh all the girls
that were Martin you know like I I just
go I go I don't know I feel like it's
been it's got too many white thumb
prints on it right it's white people
saying oh this will be a good
because that's what those are zits them
saying hey we need 20 million dollars
get this cast white committee making a
black man yeah yeah and I liked I liked
the madea because I go it's him it's an
authentic black voice it's the thing I
liked about about Nate Parker I like
that it's a black person making their
thing so what I like about hip-hop like
I don't like I don't whatever but that's
so to the point and it's the thing why
like I always gotta give Tyler Perry
credit like I don't know that my D is
for me but it doesn't matter because and
I and I respect anybody that's like my
company my scripts my way and we're
going to make movies for this specific
demographic is democratic gender sir
yeah yeah that's how everyone mean you
know that's how all of us are in
podcasting are finding like so many of
our podcasts wouldn't traditional media
wouldn't have let us do these you know
it's exact you're entirely right I don't
like the podcast that come out of the
corporation or they're like let's do
this because they seem to be selling
well like I don't like that i like the
authentic ones yeah and there's some
there's i'm actually really good black
podcast not enough in my opinion at all
you know you got to dote girls which is
a good 12 top Queens to dub Queens yeah
yeah yeah Burt it's chrissa judo Queens
you know it's funny I just found a new
cool podcast a vmail like great camps
have you listened to drink table looking
dealing the podcast is a really cool
little podcast these two girls out of
Florida I believe they're both mixed
ethnicities yeah so there's body has
those mixed feelings and they just
reached out to me like hey we think it's
cool what you know what you do with pod
fest and everything and I was like
started listen to I'm like this is
awesome yeah what are the thing i love
about about about podcasting and youtube
is traditional media is telling you know
so you're start your own [ __ ] create
your own world i love that yeah i love
that the next movie big shot up in the
DIA yes yeah jack reacher to all about
you said you saw this one well you know
Chris you see the trailer and you're
like Jack Reacher is gonna he's in a
pickle how is he gonna get out of it i
mean he's it goes all the way to the top
he loses if he's in too deep pubs on a
major anymore oh he's not he's not with
them
more what's going to happen I was on
pins and needles yeah well guess what
Jack Reacher's gonna [ __ ] set things
right there is this story what is this
because you know what I watch this on
the airplane and I was like Jack Reacher
one was okay but not like sequel it like
like I'm dying and hear more from this
research gentleman like like what was
like I just I don't like did a
Scientologist write it and that's why
they're making so many haha this is um
you know it is it is his production you
know I'm sure Paul away but now
specifically wick is did he did he go
back you know what Chrissy did blah and
guess who [ __ ] fix some [ __ ] ok god
damn Richard took care of you got a
daughter wait if you have a daughter in
this one oh no no no no I kind of yeah
it's because because he thinks gives a
daughter and then they kidnapper and
then it finds out I'm not technically
your dad yeah but i'm still can i've
never met this woman oh yeah i watch on
the plane lumpy [ __ ] now i go it now I
can marry her yeah like I here's what
I'll say it was just it was all it was
it was all Jack Reacher ified it was
everything if they're gonna just keep
cranking these out fine yeah you know I
watch it again tomorrow and I will tell
you course because I don't remember half
of it and I do all I need to see if tom
cruise with that perfect smile now and
just perfect he's in he's 53 or
something and he's in great shape and
you know he's he's still kicking out he
still kick it out the trailer i love the
trailer where every single shot of the
trailer he was punching somebody in the
face yeah and because that's what Jack
Reacher does what he had like I have him
read enough getting lost in a bar no and
he's not going back not know I should
punch you in the face don't go back no
cuz they're in 2d goes all the way at
the top yeah it was it was everything
you'd want it to be what was mastermind
this was a patrick stewart movie from
the 90 s nonce differently different
mastermind now this is where ya and kate
mckinnon um I learned that van Chris
down wave yeah it you know comedy
trailers I was like yeah i saw i saw the
trailer to I was like I was like I get
it
the 25 million dollar budget it had a
six million dollar opening weekend I
mean I love everything Zach does I look
I think doesn't like some of these ones
where I go I don't know and it was based
on a true story I think he could have
made it a little realer for me and I
would have gotten into it more you're
right and i think it was exactly make it
more by the way i don't mean to critique
anyone's are because i know that i'm not
making movies but i do think had it been
a little more tangible characters and
not look like such a spoof well i think
that's too me too me when I'm when I'm
like grounded more exactly what I'm
critical of this I'm not being critical
of Zack or Kristen Wiig I'm critical it
just feels like studio comedy says hey
we bought the rights to this true story
let's make it wet and wacky and like
make it more real and grounded it would
be able to connect it with me a lot
because I just because I was like I was
like I understand it's a true story but
you're making it looks so unbelievable
but I you can fix a lot of movies just
by saying yeah the Coen brothers should
have directed it exactly is a disease I
mean yeah that is a very accurate
statement this had six screenwriters
right which is just like oh that's great
for comedy more people with more
opinions and pleat you know yeah yeah
get the Coen brothers are doing I gotta
tell you what I only say this to defend
shitty movies like masterminds in my
opinion but like i have written shorts
and it's really hard to write something
on paper and make it funny when you
shoot it it really is difficult so like
I'm not nothing taken away from these
guys but I that that's my money morning
quarterback I said yeah well that's the
problem I think we all have been in this
situation a great podcast Monday Morning
Quarterback opean I've got notes I and
you review the flops of the week and you
just go I've got notes and you tell them
how you would have fixed it I bring him
on the show I've got notice okay you may
may you chose to cut your hair in a
weird way Zach why was that I didn't
like his beard to be happier yeah what
yeah what did you why did you why don't
we can zach galifianakis I would like
just go and fix flop movies oh I'd fix
the [ __ ] out of some let's do let's do
one let's do one just for fun one day
all right let's do it at bonus episode
yes
bonus episode called I've got no and
we'll all watch that one of the biggest
flops and will well studio exec it all
right yeah I will fix a lady in the
water oh is it have to be told you money
right off that wine moving I mean I'm
still connected to the wine Eric your
energy same character kind of how would
own Wilson be in this could we have done
it a beach instead of a pool condo Kamya
what is this pool condo in philly and
nothing looks like this in philly I
don't understand that really feels like
Salvador back to be silly because it has
to be really all right another thing on
DVD queen of a cot way I saw this movie
it is anyway on a on a plane yeah I did
see this on a plane as a matter of fact
way anyone who's listening is already
knows that I definitely have not seen
this movie it wasn't marketed for me me
but you should see it okay it's an
excellent film because it's it's about a
girl from it's a true story based on
this girl that comes from this like poor
village in Uganda that becomes a chess
champion and Bert nominations by the way
it was weird it got shunned and I'm it
was a bummer i don't know why did it get
it released too early in the year or
something because there's some fantastic
performances in this Lupita and young
goes in it yeah she plays her mom she's
great that's the actress from 12 years
of slave she's she's a really solid
actress the young girl is fantastic and
i started crying i was crying on the
plane it's like oh yeah bird you're
gonna cry the [ __ ] out of the queen of
kart or catch way yeah right i'll watch
it it's it's fantastic it's great
performances i mean it's it's um it's a
true story and i believe i believe
disney yet disney did it looks it's
disney yes it's all disney storify but
to be clear to jon hamm not in it jon
hamm is not in this cuz that and by the
way in our episode of I've got notes how
do we market this to the to the white 18
to 35 year old put John and John does
that does she have to be a Ugandan a
black Ugandan can you know what about
him like Russell Crowe we get Russell
Crowe in there he teaches your chest
ham is the President of Uganda John
Malkovich they'll believe him as a chess
champ but yeah it it it didn't do that
great as a box office maybe that's why
it had a an estimated fifty million
dollar budget it's really only done
eight million dollars since its
September release but it was a good
movie and and it's worth watching it's
one of those ones that slipped under the
right air but there's some great
performances and it's a true story and
they shoot it I think they shot in South
Africa but they shoot it in these like
poor villages and you see like what a
shantytown and what that life is like it
should have as well we regretted there's
a lot of reasons why yeah they're gone
under the rim but it's were thing it's
worth thing very cool all right and in
the site spotlight and the fan feedback
when they get a lot of great tweets and
feedback on the Facebook page as well as
the message board Neil's weekly film
news is up and there's a bunch of really
interesting reviews on the site right
now you got to check it out somebody
okay so I was on Jimmy doors podcast and
which he also has this big YouTube
channel he's quite successful called the
jimmy dore show and so there was a
segment where he we just talked about
earbuds and then he released that video
on his jimmy dore show youtube channel
someone who's like a loyalist to his
show was like i went to the comedy film
his website website and they misspelled
weekly for the weekly haha so it's neil
and I wrote underneath I was like his
the author's name is weekly wek luy that
it was a play on words because he does a
weekly wek like there's [ __ ]
fantastic better than razo fantastic I
used to watch J mores more sports on
ESPN but they misspelled more thank you
know he did more specifically what oh
good um so that was fantastic that is
great check that out and go to our go to
our facebook page guys we like the we
like to comment on the stuff so that we
can yeah it's great and you know we've
had a couple issues with the message
boards it should all be fixed now we had
our webmaster working very diligently
over the last week or so the pages
should be loading quicker the message
board
be more available and everything should
be working properly now but you know and
if it doesn't let us know at info at
comedy film nerds calm a lot of times
you guys are our beta testers yeah so we
appreciate it when you let us know
something's broken also we put some
comments that was posted about the this
is Sebastian Stan face showed us
photoshopped onto mark hamill if Star
Wars ever need a young luke and then
Brian rally wrote or when winter soldier
2055 gets greenlit they'll have Mark
Hamill thank you for that comment Brian
um alright what's coming out this week
we've got ring oh won't watch that i'm
not i don't i do not need that my life
girl already came out of the TV I can't
I'm never watching these movie because I
have a hard time sleeping the comedian
that isn't it that's the robert de niro
one right that's the robert de niro one
or comic yeah and the space between us
with an Jeff Ross I think wrote on the
majority of that movie really I don't
know yeah wow that maybe I shouldn't say
that out loud because I don't know but I
think Jeff was the one who wrote all the
jokes in it oh yeah the space between I
feel like we've promoted that movie for
months on different release dates a big
if you actually keeps getting a push
back yeah so Jeff Ross is listed as one
of the screenwriters yeah art lindsten
Jeff Ross and a couple other people
fashion comedian I am NOT your knee girl
we were talking about that that's an
oscar-nominated doc that I haven't seen
yet but I heard it's interesting because
all the trailer look at tough yeah see
how that's that's up my alley good yeah
I'm going to see I'm trying to see all
of the nominees I try to see all the
nominees every year obviously but next
one is journey to the west the demon
strike back so the first journey to the
west movie it was absolutely insane it's
on streaming right now hold all what is
this I'm freaking loved Anna [ __ ] i
would i would start with the first one
yeah but it's it's it's the only way to
describe it is insane monsters martial
arts comedy it love it love it i love
I love that that's why you should never
give me money to make a movie yeah mix
between the time traveler's wife and
journey to the west you don't talking
about yeah I'm all is not going for that
we said notes can we act I'm probable
that every guys with five double oven
it's that it's a world war two love
we're having a hard time getting
wrapping up the ending rule maker the
time travel movie time portal is it and
before this movie showed up on screening
was one of the movies that rick mirer
sent us on DVD and when i'll check this
out was for weird i'm like oh my god
this is great all right go insane and
Stephen Chow from come to hustle and
brags other is it his moldy or is he
just in it he's not in it he actually
was for the original one he was I
believe one of the writers okay I don't
know if he wrote the second one or not
but if it's anything like the first one
it's going to be nuts and just a bunch
of crazy sci-fi special effects monsters
fantasy everything all kind of put
together mish-mosh of of and it's just
fun they're just it was a fun movie so
there's either horror elements to it it
literally we're going to take pieces
from everything and put it together all
right okay well that's our episode lady
I'm General Santos work twice your first
time guess thanks for being on dammit
part [ __ ] time yeah and we got to do
that extra I've got notes yeah let me
make a movie and do I've got to pick a
movie that and that we can fix that we
can fix yeah you see some of that on the
road just text me and go Graham I just
saw okay call this on a plan that makes
this makes my flight tomorrow night to
Lexington so much more enjoyable because
i know that i'll get on the plane and go
i'm looking for the shittiest movie
longer and it'll be on the plane oh
they'll have it oh yeah sure play
finally watch whatever the one with the
girl with a glass of wine with the fun
set behind her is sure yeah that ever
thought what it sounds like a corona
commercial oh yeah that's right we're on
the camera yeah just like that up more
hammock yeah time traveling hammock I'm
dropping him and I like to face you
about a bird so where can people find
you on the internet / dates when he got
going on go to Bert Bert Bert calm with
an E and I should have everything I'm on
tour
fairly aggressively for the next 18
weeks I'm doing 18 weeks straight and
then i'll be in London and then you can
get my podcast broadcast grams like five
episodes ago four episodes blast yeah
and it's a great podcast the one with
Grandma my podcast is great but and then
today I'm releasing dr. drew today and
then my wife and I are trying to start
this thing if you're a fan of black
sails we're big fans of black sails and
Game of Thrones so what we're going to
do is I don't really pay attention very
well in TV shows I'm sure you're shocked
this is so we watch it and then she
explains the episode I just watched
Kimmy and so and then I get that with a
game of Thrones episode please yes yeah
I've read all the books too oh really
yes you liked when the game of thrones
starts coming you want to come on for
lose oh my god you come up just come
over on Sunday we'll watch it together
me or my wife and then at the end I'll
go okay who's the guy hahaha and so my
wife does it then it we did one cuz i
said i had the creator of Game of
Thrones oddly enough named Jason
Steinberg there's a comedian manager
named chief tiberg but I had him on my
podcast it was great but I was like I'm
not done with this show it's the last
season I was like let's just do it and
then my website will do it and we'll do
it for Game of Thrones or that starts up
I was like hell yeah and because I think
that's one of my favorite things is the
one of the best part about being married
is you get to watch a show with somebody
right you know and that we did it for
the Biggest Loser and it sounds like
let's just do it and this isn't there's
no rules why can't I just put a dr. drew
episode then at the last 15 minutes hey
guys doing a listen to this is extra
this is on the end so we're gonna do
that and then we'll do that for Game of
Thrones awesome I can't wait thank you
guys for having me i really appreciate
it yeah and thanks for being on the show
and it sounds like you know and that
process dates to release and a lamp is
released it might be an Atlantis come on
all right guys yeah thanks for listening
ear buds is for sale guys download into
DVD autographed copies seibert's
interview in it bonus outage of you know
I think preston & steve riemann sum of
the bonus footage oh yeah there's a
whole thing on precedence yeah so
alright you got it right there so go to
obviously comedy filmous.com all the
things you can do for free like us all
that business
I got a new political youtube channel
called political vigilante so go to
youtube name yeah for sure we tried
sucked into the trademark Church of
Batman we checked YouTube's trademark
and they're like Batman know right
somebody said to me the only thing more
scary than Batman has Warner Brothers
lore lawyers hahaha so they're like
Disney with their logo back to it I was
like nope we're pulling that out of
there so it's called political vigilante
so if you go to youtube.com / Grand
mellott it's on my playlist check that
out and earbuds guys like it share it
show it to people okay well I wanted to
tell you guys about a Kickstarter that
I'm involved with it's not a comedy film
nerds thing but it's something that if
you like the show you would like I a
bunch of old television writers got
together and were horrified at the trump
presidency and this is guys like from
bosom buddies Night Court and just all
these old TV shows they're still around
they're still writing and they got
together to create a friend would
tonight to remember foreign with yet one
of the writers and creators of that to
put together a trump style version of
that for YouTube like in his garage
where this old the host is trying to
audition for the Trump TV that he knows
is coming so it'll be like a firm Oh
tonight fake kind of talk show so check
it out it's the Alton right show alp OMW
righ T it's on kickstart I think they
just started so it's got like four days
left but i'll be one of the the writers
on it if it goes right so it'll be it'll
be really fun alright guys that's our
show thank you so much too Bert
Kreischer my name is Graham Elwood and
I'm Chris Mancini and as always remember
han shot first
you